at this moment there are at least ten
areas in sound where looters have broken
in and where fire bombs have set fires
it looks like a b-52 raid in Detroit
isn't that amazing that is John Park
reporting for CBS News 50 years ago on
the social unrest that ignited the city
of Detroit police raided an unlicensed
bar in a black neighborhood in 1967 and
that led to the 12th street riots the
violence was in response to police
brutality and decades of racial
inequality over five days more than 40
people died and more than 2,000
buildings were damaged or destroyed the
new movie Detroit centers on that
brutality that happened at the Algiers
motel during the riots three unarmed
black teenagers were shot dead by white
police officers Detroit is directed by
Kathryn Bigelow of The Hurt Locker and
zero dark thirty actor Anthony Mackie
portrays a real-life Vietnam War veteran
who was at the motel says right there
paratrooper eight years two deployments
honorable discharge this is a fake no
sir mr. girl I just met what's his name
I don't know his name is Carl Green
wasn't asking you I was asking her
what's this area what's his name you're
lucky I haven't broken your neck yet all
right I see what you're trying to do I'm
not gonna cause any trouble okay but I'm
not gonna lie down for you either
Kathryn Bigelow and Anthony Mackie are
with us now in their first live
interview together for the movie good
morning great for both of you here
Entertainment Weekly says it's quote an
American Horror Story Rudin so deep
deeply and shamefully in home soil that
it is still painful to watch half a
century later and it is painful painful
to watch and so relatable to dysentery
what made you want to tell this story
well predominantly that that it is so
relatable to today when I was first
introduced to it it was right around the
time of Ferguson Missouri and I'm
thinking this is 50 years ago today and
yet it's happening today it's happen
tomorrow it's happening you know it's
recurring far too often and so I hope
that it could perhaps invite a dialogue
to encourage a bridge between an
incredible racial divide in this country
did it feel very personal for you
Anthony very much so
you know it's funny being a parent of
little boys you know you try to put do
work that they can watch and relate and
learn from and when I read this script
and read green and that character
specifically I knew Catherine would give
me that opportunity how did you go about
it Catherine in terms as a director in
terms of finding real-life stories that
you could incorporate into the movie
well as predominantly I used court
records and testimonies and FOIA
requests the information that we got
from that so tremendous amount of
research and Mark Boal who wrote The
Hurt Locker and zero dark thirty wrote
the screenplay and it was I thought a
really tremendous screenplay and also
met with real-life people who were
involved in this incident there was
Melvin dis Muse in the movie played by
John boyega and Hannah Murray is the
character of Julie who is the real
character Julie Hisle who is with me on
the set every day and then Larry Reed
who plays a member of the of a Motown
group called the dramatics and so
hearing their rendition of this
situation and the horror that they went
through really galvanized my
determination to tell the story good
Detroit happened today the teams of all
far too likely in many respects but
think but I'm really encouraged by a
conversation beginning there was a
screening last night on Capitol Hill
hosted by representative Conyers who's
in the movie who's in the movie by Laz
Alonso and he is is furthering a bill to
end racial profiling and so I think this
film could hopefully hopefully encourage
that conversation Katherine John boyega
said this about you the other day she
asked me to read the friggin phone book
I would do that anything I want to talk
to you about your character because he's
still living did you meet with him
before you took this part well he he
hasn't we haven't been able to find him
we just wanted to meet with him no
because as an actor the best tool you
have is what the writer gives you an
estimate and what I would hate to have
happen was have a meet one chance
meeting with this man in inform or
correct what we had created with this
story I feel like it was more important
for someone like Mark Boal to meet him
and then create that but I think it says
a lot about his character and dignity
that he was the first person to speak
out about this tragedy he was one of the
the guys in the in the hotel being a
military vet that had understanding of
how to survive and I think with this
movie the most important message that
comes out of it is survival
you could have laughed when I asked
whether the question about could do try
it happen today because you think that
it the possibility of just needing an
incident to cause a city to go up in
flames I think if you look at the 1920s
if you look at the 1960s if you look at
the 2000 teens we are right now in that
decade of turmoil and combustion I feel
like America every 50 years goes through
a resurgence of growth of growth and
from that growth the country transforms
dramatically and right now we're in that
that pressure cooker that all we need to
do is add a match and it will explode
and the two of you haven't been together
since Hurt Locker I thinking there must
be a comfort level between the two of
you yeah what it was like on a set that
I would think would be buried it was
very tough watching the movie for me
what this must have been like on the set
yeah for both of you you know there was
a common understanding there was a
common understanding on set and it was a
safe zone and Kathryn is very good at
putting her actors in a progressive
affordable environment to do good work
Kathryn well I just was so honored to be
able to work with Anthony again I it
it's a memory I'll treasure forever
all right well we'll be right back stay
with us